[Musique]
retour sur la manifestation parisienne
d'hier contre le front national
arlette laguiller dans le cortège a
appelé à voter blanc ou nul au second
tour de l'élection dès dimanche dernier
elle avait précisé qu'elle n'appellera
pas à voter pour le président sortant
helen hughes une foule compacte et
unanime contre l'extrême droite mais au
milieu du cortège un groupe se distingue
sur les moyens de lui faire barrage ces
luttes ouvrières et sa stratégie du ni
ni ni le pen ni chirac
je n'appelle pas d'abord à voter le pen
sur tout et je demande aux travailleurs
qu'ils l'ont fait au premier tour de ne
pas le faire au deuxième
ensuite je n'appelle pas à voter chirac
et je demande à mes camarades à ceux qui
me font confiance et bien de voter blanc
ou nul dans cette élection
une position que dénonce l'immense
majorité des manifestants même si avant
d'être pour chirac ils sont d'abord
hostile à le pen
il n'empêche le 5 mai il vous trouve
pour le président sortant
vous savez ce n'est qu'au maire de paris
en fait c'est le moment de penser à la
nuit
le 5 mai il faut pas hésiter alors
mettez des gants sur les éparses ou je
te couplet mais voter ab c'est pas
possible pas toute la gauche plurielle
appelle à en faire de même le 5 mai la
ligue communiste révolutionnaire d'alain
krivine et olivier besancenot ne s'est
pas encore prononcé vote blanc ou votre
chirac
une décision sera prise mardi
[Musique]